foreign
monthly ritual that an American goes
somewhere overseas somewhere outside the
Western bubble and discovers the hard
way that the rules are different in that
part of the world Brittany Greiner is of
course the most high profile recent
example but there have been others for
instance we heard last week about the
odd story of private second class Travis
King who managed to get himself arrested
in North Korea now we don't know exactly
what happened or why but we do know that
the first and most glaring mistake that
leads an American to getting arrested in
North Korea is that they go to North
Korea I have found that for me the most
effective way to avoid North Korean
imprisonment is to not ever be in North
Korea
why did Travis King pay the communist
country a visit well the details are odd
uh and still a little bit unclear but
NBC news reports quote private second
class Travis King 23 was about to fly
back to United States from South Korea
for possible disciplinary action
disciplinary action after refusing to
pay a fine for allegedly damaging public
property He Slipped Away from the
airport in Seoul last Tuesday and
managed to join a guided tour to the
Joint security area a piece of land
between the North and South that's
managed by the U.N
from there he sprinted across the border
and appeared to be detained by North
Korean guards
now apparently he didn't want to face
disciplinary action in the United States
and so instead he'll face it in North
Korea
which is kind of like I don't know
curing the pain of a paper cut on your
finger by chopping your entire arm off
effective I guess in a certain sense but
Overkill perhaps
Travis king is not the only American to
find himself in the illegal crosshairs
in a country that isn't exactly renowned
for its leniency a similar Fate has
befallen a woman named Tierra Allen
otherwise known as on Tick Tock and
YouTube as The Sassy trucker
and she got herself arrested a couple of
months ago in Dubai now if you think
that a self-described sassy woman and
the Middle East do not seem like
necessarily the best combination then
you'd be correct before we get into the
legal dispute let's first meet The Sassy
trucker who has amassed a respectable
following on social media with content
like this watch
[Music]
foreign
anyways I had got called in to come pick
up the trailer I was leaving a party
it's always business before pleasure
that's why you see me wearing his green
beautiful outfit as you can see I was
looking like a snack
[Music]
the money don't stop so why should I
now
to be honest I was expecting a little
more sass
maybe The Sassy part is the outfit as
The Sassy trucker apparently enjoys
doing her long hauls in a spandex
jumpsuit which makes her I'm sure the
only person at the truck stop dressed
like a backup dancer from a Britney
Spears video in 2003 but this is not why
she was arrested in Dubai although she
likely would have been had she dressed
like that in Dubai the actual reason had
to do with a dispute at a rental car
agency the AP reports quote a Houston
woman known online as The Sassy trucker
has been stuck in Dubai for months after
an altercation at a car rental agency
the latest case showing the limits of
speech in this skyscraper-studded
city-state the case against Tierra young
Allen 29 comes as seven sheikdums of the
United Arab Emirates have rules that
strictly govern speech far beyond what's
common in Western Nations a middle
finger raised in a traffic dispute a
text message calling somebody a name or
swearing in public can easily spark
criminal cases something that foreign
tourists who flock here may not realize
until it's too late
uh Allen traveled to Dubai in April with
her social media accounts with tens of
thousands of followers showing videos of
her test driving a Mercedes semi truck
going to a beach seeing tourist
attractions and partying and nightclubs
towards the end of Allen's trip a rental
car driven by a friend she was with was
involved in a crash on April 28th said
Radha Sterling who runs a four hire
advocacy group uh long critical of the
UAE called detained in Dubai
after the crash Allen tried to retrieve
personal items from inside the car at
the rental agency sparking altercation
Sterling said now the details from here
are sketchy this Sterling person says
that the sassy trucker shouted at a
rental car employee though we aren't
told exactly what she said but Sterling
says that the employee started it that
this person yelled first and was being
confrontational
now Dubai Police on the other hand
claimed that the aggression went the
other way quote
the Dubai Police received a complaint
from a car rental office accusing her of
slandering and defaming an employee
amidst a dispute over car rental fees
police said in their statement the
individual is questioned as per legal
procedures and subsequently released
pending the resolution of ongoing legal
proceedings between her and the car
rental office
now whatever the case
The Sassy trucker cannot leave the
country until the investigation is
completed and a decision has been made
about whether to prosecute if they do
she could be looking at several months
or even a year in prison for this the AP
notes quote the state department
separately warns Travelers coming to the
UAE that quote individuals may be
arrested fined and or deported for
making rude gestures swearing and making
derogatory statements about the UAE the
royal families the local governments or
other people under uh emirati law
publicly insulting another person can
carry a sentence of up to one year in
prison and a fine of five thousand four
hundred fifty dollars disputes over
rental car agency fees have seen other
foreign tourists stuck in the city state
in the past as well
in other words
the UAE is not a place for your
sassiness even if you are The Sassy
trucker they literally have laws against
being sassy it is against the law to be
sassy
and this comes as news to many Americans
it's clear that the left is giving up
their morals and any Common Sense
there's no better time to build a daily
habit of prayer meditation than right
now building a habit of prayer can help
you cultivate an attitude of gratitude
focusing on what you're thankful for can
increase positive emotions and improve
overall well-being hallow is the number
one Christian Prayer app in the U.S it's
helped me maintain a daily prayer
routine could help you do the same
download the app for free at hollow.com
Matt Walsh you can set prayer reminders
track your progress along the way if
you're not sure where to start we'll
check out father Mike schmitz's Bible in
a year podcast for brief daily readings
and Reflections or you can pray
alongside the likes of Mark Wahlberg Jim
Caviezel even some world-class athletes
as well with how low you can customize a
personal prayer plan that works for you
listen wherever you are with
downloadable offline sessions using
hello to connect with other others who
share your beliefs and values can
provide a sense of belonging support and
Foster a sense of community as well
ultimately we'll learn how we can become
better individuals in spite of today's
broken World As We strive to become more
like Christ in our daily lives through
prayer fasting and giving download
hello.com Matt Walsh and get exclusive
three months free that's free months
absolutely
that's three months absolutely free at
howlo.com slash Matt Walsh
Walsh we see in these kinds of stories
the startling fact that the whole world
is not America
you have many privileges here that you
don't have anywhere else
many Americans don't understand that
these privileges are privileges they
have gotten so used to basically acting
however they want and doing whatever
they want and saying whatever they want
that that they they've come to believe
that the Universe owes them these
freedoms
but then they go somewhere else in the
world and they find that the universe is
no longer delivering the way it was
before they can kick and scream and say
but I have the right to act this way
this isn't fair
I'm The Sassy trucker damn it
this is my whole stick
and yet they've uh wound up in a place
that doesn't care how unfair it feels to
them doesn't care what they feel they
are owed
now I don't know what exactly led to the
sassy truckers arrest I suspect that
whoever started it she was being quite
sassy this is what I've ascertained
based on context clues
and if that is the case then she's the
latest American to learn and learn the
hard way that our culture is quite
unique in its seemingly endless capacity
to tolerate unpleasant Behavior
that is the path that we have chosen as
a society the path that empowers and
enables obnoxious people now many other
countries came to the same fork in the
road and chose to go the other way
they don't recognize any right to say
and do whatever you want no matter how
vulgar boorish or indecent it may be we
can insist that such rights exist but
our insistence doesn't mean much in
Practical terms
these other countries will respond by
asking us where these rights exist
how we know that we all have them or
should have them
and in what way do they make our lives
and our culture better
you know so we could say the other
countries well we have these rights and
you know
you should guarantee these rights for
other people too you should have a
country where people can go to the
rental car agency and and yell and
scream and there'll be no consequence
for it you should have that kind of
country too but these other countries we
say that to them and they say why would
we want that kind of country how does
that benefited you is a major life
better is it major culture better is are
you happier because of this
those are fair questions aren't they
most Americans will have no answer for
any of those questions they haven't even
thought about them
and these are the people who get
blindsided in these kind of situations
now I'm not saying that I'd prefer to
live in a place like Dubai or that we
should adopt the same laws and simply
staying
some facts about the world
whether we like it or not
but there is good news for The Sassy
trucker Joe Biden is still in office for
now anyway and we know that he's willing
to make trades no matter how insane they
might be so perhaps soon we'll hear that
the sassy trucker is headed home after
the bite Administration secured her
Freedom with a trade that gives the UAE
the entire Eastern Seaboard of the
United States or something
whatever it takes to get the sassy
trucker back any trade is worth it
at least that's been Biden's approach
you know it wouldn't be mine though
which is why I will say that not to add
insult to injury but I think today it is
The Sassy trucker who is canceled if
you'd like to see what else I have to
say you can access my full show by going
to dailywire.com or by going to the Matt
Walsh Show Twitter page hope to see you
there Godspeed